i don't consider myself like an awake
person but i do consider myself
recently curious and thoroughly amazed
cool that's great by kind of just my own
ability
to have something different than i
thought my [ __ ] word than
than i thought the world was and it's so
scary
uh to realize that there's more out
there than this
very specific world that i had created
and that i needed a lot of times for
survival
you know growing up if you grew up in
like in a tough environment or in a you
know environment there's not a lot of
feelings and love then you can cr
you'll create whatever you have to
whatever checks and balances makes sense
for you for survival
yeah um that's right but to get out of
that now and like
yeah it's like you kind of push and
you're like oh [ __ ] a board fell off
this back wall and like what's out here
yeah and you reach out there and like
the air feels different and you're like
[ __ ] dude yeah i'm gonna sleep tonight
but tomorrow i'll look out there yes
um that's cool how does somebody start
to kind of do that
most people are living in these two
lives
yes the thought realm in this world
and most of us are getting jerked back
and forth between those two
and we don't even realize it you don't
even realize that i mean if you want to
think of something really [ __ ] up
and really a true mind [ __ ]
you don't remember much that you do the
odds are you're living
in a forgotten memory you're walking
through a memory that you won't ever
remember again
yeah you're you when you really look
back into the past and
contemplate your life it's not some
continuous
like it's not like you're watching a dvd
yeah it's a
it's a it's it's a it's like 70 or 80
blurbs
yeah this [ __ ] merges together and you
kind of
fades in and out and there's these clear
moments where you look back at it but
even that has this
kind of wavering quality to it so when
you realize like oh [ __ ] like yeah
i'm not even gonna this i'm not gonna
remember the chipotle i had
six months ago right i mean do you eat
chipotle
well you definitely don't remember it
but like what what's uh what's up what's
like
what's that's yeah you just made me
think i had some guavas a couple years
ago that i [ __ ] never would have
thought about
there you gotta mention this the guavas
or whatever
i don't know man think like i guarantee
a decade ago
oh yeah i had raisins probably i had a
lot more turkey sandwiches i'm going to
guess
a decade ago that you had a really nice
meal yeah
i mean it was [ __ ] good and it was
maybe expensive
yeah and you maybe were on a date or
something i don't know yeah
and you were sitting there eating it
thinking like this is so [ __ ] good
and you don't remember it now right it's
gone
it's gone it's gone it's gone it's gone
so this is the thing when you begin to
realize like oh
most of the time i'm not even here at
all i'm up in my head
wow while i'm eating that meal i'm
thinking about
something that happened to me as a kid
or i'm worrying that this girl thinks
i'm a dick or
i'm concerned over how much it's going
to cost or i'm beating myself up for
eating out
and so i'm not even eating the meal you
know that's the thing so
through that you start realizing like oh
[ __ ] look at this crazy way
humans live that uh yeah when you start
to become aware that your thoughts
you know we're like we're kind of like
um
whales we sir we breach
in this reality and we come into the
moment
and we're here and then we go back down
in
to our thoughts yeah and we swim in
those
waters of of our consciousness and then
we breach again
yeah and then we go back down and that
that rhythm
kind of makes up a human life so it's
interesting to start becoming aware
of the of that's actually what you're
doing i'm just sitting on your front
porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
[Music]
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been